hey youtubers it's Charlie so Zack
Snyder finally revealed Ben Affleck's
Batsuit and the Batmobile it gives off a
very dark night returns five but he use
this like em camera so the photo is
black and white so we didn't get a
really good you know full color look but
we do know a few other things about them
so I'm gonna do a breakdown of the suit
and the Batmobile if you're finding me
for the first time I do DC videos every
week normally it's arrow like on
Wednesdays associated with that but
Batman waits for no one so obviously
this is coming out on a Tuesday be sure
to subscribe to get everything and leave
me suggestions for future bonus videos
so first things first the suit and the
car are what they're using for Superman
versus Batman the Man of Steel sequel
this Batman is much older a la Ben
Affleck's 50-something Batman vs.
Christian Bale's 30-something version of
the character the suit itself reinforces
the idea that they adapted Frank
Miller's Dark Knight Returns Ark
although not literally it just inspired
Ben Affleck's character in the story
Batman is way more jaded in the world is
just gone dead so naturally he's
just beefed up his arsenal obviously
things haven't gotten quite so bad in
Zack Snyder's Man is still universe but
Batman and Superman in this movie are
not gonna start out of his best buds
so naturally Bruce wayne/batman in this
movie is bringing out the big guns the
first time he meets up with Superman
which is where the much more armored
looking suit and car come from you can't
tell because of the black and white
photo but the raised portions of the
suit are silver its silver plates on
black Tech fabric so they combined the
defensive nature of Christian Bale's
first suit with the modularity of the
second suit and just made it a little
bit shinier so supposedly it's supposed
to look pretty freakin cool so here's a
look of the suit from Frank Miller's
Dark Knight Returns this is where the
comparisons are coming from it's really
Ben Affleck's ear pieces that evoke the
look this Batman always reminded me of
the Frank Castle Punisher just you know
beating the crap out of villains
supposedly that's going to be what the
initial meeting of Batman and Superman
is going to be in the Man of Steel
sequel Batman sees what happened to
Metropolis in the wake of general Zod's
battle and armors up appropriately
remember when that first movie came out
there was this big conversation going on
about the amount of damage Superman and
Zod did to Metropolis during their fight
it was like watching a little kid stomp
through someone's lego bottle you know
they didn't hundreds of
of dollars of damage to the city so if
you were the world's greatest detective
and the most cynical superhero on the
planet what would you do you would
probably beef up your arsenal the
Batmobile itself looks a lot sleeker
than Christian Bale's tumbler which is
funny because it looks more like a real
car than the comic and the Batmobile
that inspired the story in the Dark
Knight Returns the Batmobile is
basically a full-on tank so it's almost
like Zach Snyder went in the opposite
direction I do think it's a more
practical approach based on the movie
that they're really making because
Batman is going up against Superman not
like against an army of thugs so a tank
really wouldn't help him that much you
know it's not fast at all he needs
something smaller and quicker I'm really
interested to find out what kind of
extra weaponry he's developed too
they're not completely throwing away all
the cannon from Christopher Nolan's Dark
Knight trilogy but they're not really
addressing anything from those movies
either I still consider Ben Affleck's
version of the character to be the
logical evolution of Christian Bale's
character though we also can't forget
about Wonder Woman and cyborg because
essentially this movie is gonna be like
a backdoor world's finest Justice League
movie before the actual Justice League
movie I think it's gonna take most of
the plot for the Trinity to come
together so I'm really interested to see
what their chemistry is like especially
whenever they first meet if you haven't
read any of DC comics and new 52
versions of Justice League they
essentially got Wonder Woman and
Superman together as a romantic couple
and even though they worked together now
whenever they first met Batman pulled
out some Kryptonite the first couple of
times he met Superman so don't be
surprised if Ben Affleck has the famous
kryptonite ring in the movie it would be
a pretty sweet shout out to the comics
before the new 52 reboot of the comics
Batman historically kept a kryptonite
ring with him in case Superman ever went
crazy I don't know how the movie is
going to address this but in the comics
Superman is highly vulnerable to magic
and mind control so he's been used by
super villains as a smashy finger puppet
on many many occasions obviously magic
isn't a thing in Zack Snyder's Man of
Steel universe but here's what we need
to talk about the villain Lex Luthor
people are calling it a darker version
of the Mark Zuckerberg character from
social network let's take that with a
grain of salt but we're finally starting
to get a look at the movie which is
totally awesome I am really interested
to see what kind of methods and
their uses in this movie to deal with
Superman and regardless of what you
think about Zack Snyder's movies he's
always been really good about giving
fans an inside look I remember back at
comic-con 2008 he actually brought the a
low ship from Watchmen it was pretty
badass they built it like a real on ship
so do not be surprised at the Batmobile
is at Comic Con this year the cool
things about all the versions of the
Batmobiles are that they actually drive
Adam West's Batmobile was probably the
closest to being just a regular car and
when I was a little kid Michael Keaton's
Batmobile was completely badass but the
funny thing about that Batmobile is that
I found out it weights so much that in
real life it could not go fast at all it
was super slow that all changed though
whenever Christopher Nolan built the
tumbler and then the Batpod motorcycle
they actually drove really well the
tires were super huge so they didn't
turn super fast but the tumbler was
meant to be an urban tank that could
withstand a missile
I guess the new Batmobile has to
withstand a Superman but logically the
only way to do that would be to give it
a coat of Kryptonite paint I haven't
seen Batman use this kind of device in
the comics but I think a Kryptonite
field generator would probably be more
effective I really am expecting Lex
Luthor in this movie though to use you
know modern day tech like to deal with
Superman so that might be something he
does Zack Snyder has taken a much less
comical approach to the character so I'm
expecting a more advanced version of
Bruce Wayne's secret projects to be like
a Lex Corp thing but now it's your turn
let me know in the comments below what
do you think about the new bat suit and
the new Batmobile and how do you think
it's going to inform the movie like I
said you know Batman isn't that the
world's friendliest person so I'm really
interested to see what all their first
interactions are going to be like on
screen you know the Holy Trinity in
related news if you haven't seen there's
a bunch of huge stuff happening this
week so I'm posting a few more videos
than I normally do we're getting the
first trailer for the flash TV show and
after that arrow and agents of shield
are both having their season finales so
be sure to subscribe to get everything I
also posted a link to my master schedule
down in the description really I'm just
crossing my fingers that I make it to
the end of the week and get through all
these videos but right now click here to
learn more about the Justice League
movie
click here to learn more about that new
flash trailer thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you